[Music]
all right where were you one year ago
tonight a historic milestone it's been
one year since Donald Trump was elected
the 45th President of the United States
now the president pulled off one of the
biggest upsets American politics has
ever seen by easily defeating Hillary
Clinton now the president celebrated the
anniversary by tweeting out quote
congratulations to all the deplorable
zand the millions of people who gave us
a massive three hundred and four to 227
electoral college landslide victory now
president Trump's big win happened
despite a media and a political class
that was all unified in stopping him
from reaching the Oval Office now we
can't forget how all the pundits all the
pollsters all the experts all the people
in the know the ones that talk to each
other 24/7 they all thought it was
impossible for you to elect Donald Trump
you may remember this Donald Trump has
been saying that he will run for
president as a Republican which is
surprising since I just assumed he was
running as a joke do it on behalf of
this country which does not want you to
be president but which badly wants you
to run this man has got some momentum
and we better be ready for the fact that
he may be leading the Republican ticket
next I know you don't believe which
Republican candidate has the best chance
of winning the general election of the
declared ones right now Donald Trump
[Applause]
mr. Trump to answer your call for
political honesty I just want to say
you're not going to be President all
right it's been fun President Obama will
go down as perhaps the worst president
in the history of the United States
exclamation point at real Donald Trump
at real Donald Trump at least I will go
down as Donald Trump has won the state
of Arkansas Fox can also project that
Donald Trump will win the states of
Kansas North Dakota South Dakota Texas
and Wyoming and we are about to make a
major call Fox News decision desk is now
projecting that Donald Trump has won the
state of North Carolina
projecting that Donald Trump will win
the state of Utah a victory for Donald
Trump in Ohio can be called by the Fox
News decision desk at this point Iowa
will go to Donald Trump Donald Trump has
won the state of Wisconsin Donald Trump
will win the state of Florida the Fox
News decision desk has called
Pennsylvania for Donald Trump
this means that Donald Trump will be the
45th President of the United States ah
nothing better where were you than
hearing those swing states one after
another call for President Trump that
night now the left liberals members of
the abusively biased press in this
country you all look like idiots because
you all predicted Donald Trump never
stood a chance and then after he won you
became hysterical let's take a look
America is crying tonight I'm not sure
how much of America but a very very
significant portion and I mean literally
crying this is a sadness it is a a
mourning moment for those people and it
is a it is a moment filled with fear
filled with fear our country is about to
face some serious Christ
and so your country needs you it's a
pretty extraordinary thing to say if you
have a son in the Marine Corps and that
you don't trust the commander-in-chief
the people in the military defend the
Constitution this was a white lash this
was a white lash against a changing
country
it was a white lash against a black
president in part it's funny but it's
also pathetic and it shows you just how
abusively biased and corrupt and
dishonest the media in this country
really is the media they couldn't
understand why Donald Trump won why he
was victorious that night now the night
of election night usually at night offer
me but I was encouraged when my boss at
the time to call in and join my Fox News
colleagues to explain why he won this is
election night one year ago tonight to
me this was predictable but on the other
hand this is a a modern day political
miracle you're witnessing before your
eyes right now and that is to go up
against everybody and all the pundits
and all the pollsters and all the
prognosticators out there and defy all
the odds and it's the American people
that have said enough is enough they're
tired of the corruption the cesspool
draining the swamp all of these things
were resonating you know when you look
at a state like Wisconsin what do they
think they want their jobs back they
want the labor participation rate to be
lower in other words more people having
jobs they want America to be energy
independent they're tired of a horrible
educational system the tired of
Obamacare rates going through the roof
this is not complicated what's happening
now is not working and these guys and
Donald Trump has gone out there and he
outwork Hillary Clinton and he put
forward a much better agenda and America
said enough is enough with failed policy
that's what this election was about that
was one year ago tonight I don't forget
that just about every single news outlet
but the Fox News Channel was exposed by
WikiLeaks and Julian Assange is having
colluded with the Clinton campaign and
of course there's the liberal crybaby
snowflakes now this is a video of
Hillary Clinton
election headquarters after President
Trump delivered that crushing defeat a
year ago tonight they're probably still
crying tonight in mommy and daddy's
basement because they were triggered by
what happened we also saw schools
remember colleges they were offering
these poor grieving spoiled brats
counseling all the Liberals needed
things like therapy dogs hot cocoa
Plato just to cope in retrospect it's
actually laughable how lame these people
were and how out of touch by the way you
know for example Hollywood liberals and
celebrities they join this collective
left-wing freakout launching all kinds
of vicious and violet acts against
President Trump and it's gone on for an
entire year watch this how dare you say
the things he does of course I want to
punch him in the face I have thought an
awful lot about blowing up the White
House I am a nasty woman I'm not as
nasty as a man who looks like he bathes
in cheeto dust when was the last time an
actor assassinated the president
I want clarify I'm not an actor
[Laughter]
what a year and if you thought that was
bad we also have member Kathy Griffin's
disgusting photoshoot that we always
have to give you a viewer warning about
because it's so graphic here Griffin
posing like an Isis fighter with a fake
bloody head that looks like President
Trump and if that wasn't enough there
was the Shakespeare in the Park play
where a trump-like character was
assassinated on stage this liberal
hatred for one year no bounds do they
know and of course the destroyed Trump
media
well they got in on all the action they
become so unhinged lying dishonesty at a
level we've never seen before we've had
to no coin new terms just to describe
the Trump derangement syndrome
the media's Trump psychosis watch this
there's a sign out there that's been
hung up in the White House we're outside
the way I'll say if you're not white
you're not especially welcome this is a
man who is not well he alternated
between being a whiny six-year-old who's
had his Nintendo taken away and and
between being the cranky old man
who's out there condemning everyone who
doesn't worship Him adequately Donald
Trump short of only maybe Woodrow Wilson
and Andrew Jackson is being himself more
than any other previous president with
disgraceful racial views we can truly
say his words have absolutely emboldened
white supremacist you know this is a
it's a tough night I think for normal
people you got a lot of people at home
going through Kleenex right now I'm just
hurt I'm sitting here hurt a lot of
people hurt tonight the presidency
itself is in question our relationships
around the world in question trust in
the President himself in question he
said today America first it was not just
a racial I mean iam I should say racial
the hilarion
around 2:00 it is Donald Trump competent
to be President President Trump say
America first tonight President Trump
put himself first a little whiff of
fascism tonight I think it's fair to so
here you have a deranged president or a
pathologically lying president lying
about the operations of the American
government Trump's critics those who are
worried about this president and this
White House saw a live special
television event brought to you by
narcissism thin-skinned chaos and deeply
personal grievances imagine saying those
things about President Obama never this
media has treated presidents from so
badly even former Democratic President
Jimmy Carter was forced to admit he's
never seen anything like it and by the
way we can throw in the unprecedented
obstruction of course from the Democrats
President Trump could literally cure
cancer turn water into wine and poverty
and the left in this country in the
media would still never give him credit
they hate him that much and Democrats
have now made it clear their goal is
simple to damage and to destroy this
president by any means necessary just
look at the last year it is beyond
disgusting and it is a tremendous
disservice to you the American people
especially the Forgotten men and women
that this election was about and I've
been telling you there are five forces
actively working against this president
they did it before they're doing it now
the deep state the Democratic Party the
destroy Trump ever corrupt lying media
never Trump errs and weak spineless
establishment Republicans they were
against them before the election they
are against them even more today all
they care about is their hatred they
live on this hatred for Donald Trump
also tonight Democrats the liberal media
they're ecstatic okay they want a couple
of races last night and they were all
predicted to win those races in solid
liberal blue states now take a look at
how the media reacted to Democrats
winning
let's see states that Donald Trump
didn't win watch this that feels like
tonight's history is being written by
movie writers it is so dramatic unsubtle
movie writers this was a repudiation of
Donald Trump that will be heard around
Virginia around the nation and yes
around the world
the whole world is watching stinging
rebuke a tough election night for
President Trump and the GOP Democrats
with key victories in Virginia and New
Jersey it was a very big night for
Democrats all eyes were on Virginia
perhaps the biggest political prize
this is voters first strong rebuke of
President Trump they sent a message at
Trump big time in the course of this and
talk about when he comes back to
Washington it may be his Forbidden City
it was a night of total diversity and I
think that not only a rejection of Trump
it was basically a rejection of what he
stood for wait a minute they didn't act
like that a year ago oh they were at a
funeral a year ago he listened to that
you would think the Democrats won the
presidency had super majorities in
Congress but that is not even close to
what happened here's what did happen
Democrats scored predictable victories
in states that Donald Trump didn't win
in 2016 New Jersey shocker New York the
Commonwealth of Virginia Washington
State it was not a rebuke of the White
House or not even really surprising
let's take Virginia's gubernatorial race
ed gillespie he lost Ed Gillespie was
too timid he didn't embrace the
President's agenda and afterwards the
president even tweeted quote Ed
Gillespie worked hard but he didn't
embrace me or what I stand for
don't forget Republicans won four out of
four House seats and with the economy
doing record numbers will continue to
win even bigger than before and it
Gillespie had a chance that in fact you
have Steve manners going to join us in a
minute he offered to campaign for
Gillespie but his team declined the
president offered to campaign then in
the great liberal bastion of New Jersey
Democrats gonna be the governor next
year that's not surprising when you look
at Governor Chris Christie's poll
numbers sorry Chris but look at it
hovering around 15% couldn't be a dog
catcher away the bows numbers that's the
lowest in the nation the worst number
Quinnipiac is found in any state in more
than 20 years so it's already incredibly
difficult for a Republican to win in New
Jersey chris Christie deserves credit
for winning Christie's poll numbers made
it impossible this time but the media
will never report that as the reason
they also never reported on these facts
want to look at a president that had a
tough time look at Obama while he was in
the Oval Office Democrats lost the
presidency 13 you
les Senate seats 64 US House seats 13
governorships and 33 state houses that
is an electoral tidal-wave
what happened last night was not no
matter how the left-wing media tries to
spin it now before we move on I do want
to issue a stern warning tonight to
congressional Republicans especially you
spineless ones in the Senate you don't
start passing and the President's agenda
the things that you promised one year
from tonight you are going to face the
consequences of the 2018 midterms you
know what Republicans the American
people are sick of you making all kinds
of promises for the past eight plus
years and failing miserably to keep them
you break your promises you're gonna pay
at the polls and by the way it's not
going to be Donald Trump's fault
now finally tonight we just explained
how Democrats they're all smiles last
night but not a year ago but they
shouldn't be because their party is in
total shambles tonight now thanks to
former DNC chairwoman Donna Brazile
we're now finding out how crooked how
deeply crooked corrupt and frankly what
a lying Democratic machine Clinton and
her party friends were for example Donna
Brazile revealed she was told that she
didn't need to know about who was
funding the fake news anti-trump Russian
propaganda lying dossier really watch
this I have a question for you and I
hope you answer this honestly because
there are a lot of questions about this
Russian dossier and their evidence that
has come out that the DNC helped fund it
did you know that was happening and were
you surprised to hear it if you did I
asked one question on November 4th and I
was told that I did not need to know and
so no I did not know didn't need to know
Donna Brazile told to stop asking
questions and at the dossier none of her
business she's only the chairwoman of
the DNC she replaced that B Wasserman
Schultz and she did it for no pay and
also said she had no idea debbie
Wasserman Schultz and the current DNC
leadership has also denied any
involvement so then who knew about the
dossier and as you just heard Donna
Brazile what she was saying she was kept
in the dark because she didn't control
the money and as she revealed it was
actually Hillary Clinton in her campaign
that controlled the purse strings at the
DNC
the authority by the way when it came to
strategy personnel decision budgeting
data analytics and mailings poor Bernie
Brazil also blasts liberal fake news CNN
anchor fake Jake Tapper in her book
Brazil says that she felt betrayed by
Tapper after he criticized her for
leaking democratic debate questions to
Hillary remember the stupid Donald Duck
protesters from the campaign Donna
Brazile pointed out it was Hillary
Clinton's idea to pay those agitators to
follow Donald Trump around and Brazil
also admitted that President Trump was
right about Democrats paying protesters
also Brazil was right in that the book
the Clinton campaign was a cult there
was a reaction all this